is this for the butt or to cover the  boobs did they forget about me do I have  to tell them I'm not naked anymore hands  are cold  sit a good-enough COFF wow de nuf I can  call differently please don't make me  get on the scale  so it really [ __ ] stop it copy  straight healthy um she isn't healthy  right I'm pretty active like for the  most part if I'm on time to find  exercise  there are two stairs leading to my house  I walk up and down those every day  sometimes twice a day depending  [Music]  so uh there are kids I usually make  people buy me dinner first  what do you like to talk about when you  have your fingers inside of your patient  started that neutral that's called  colorful then I'm comfortable I'm not  comfortable I think I'd be used to this  by now  [Music]